okay so House of the Dragon deals with a
feuding family and the question over
whether a woman can take over an
esteemed family Legacy sort of like
succession with Dragons but for this
video We're Going Back to Where it All
Began throughout it we're going to be
breaking down the ultimate Chad the top
G of Westeros egg on the Conqueror don't
turn off the video it's gonna get better
I promise now his dream is mentioned a
lot throughout the series and for those
not in the know you travel to Westeros
because he saw a world for the taking
there were unlimited riches and because
he had dragons he saw it as being
something that he could easily conquer
now according to the secret past from
King to King aegon foresaw the end of
the world of men seemingly predicting
the coming of the night King to combat
this he believed a Targaryen had to be
sitting on the Iron Throne which is why
aegon LED his dragons and sisters in
order to conquer Westeros but who was
aegon and how did he come to unify the
different kingdoms of Westeros under one
Throne well that's what we're going to
be breaking down and if you enjoy the
video please hit the thumbs up button
and don't forget subscribe a breakdown
take this every day by the way thank you
for clicking this now let's get into egg
on the Conqueror aegon was born in
Dragonstone 20 BC this was during the
century of blood which followed the Doom
of Valeria you might have heard the
terms BC and AC banded about our house
of the Dragons breakdowns and the ladder
stands for after Conquest whereas BC
means before the book Fire and Blood
opens by detailing the dates of this and
truthfully we don't know the exact
specific time that AC began as the
conquest wasn't done in a day however it
gives us a rough time as to when aegon
arrived and changed Westeros the
Targaryen Lords had fled to Dragonstone
prior to the Doom of Valeria at a Danish
Targaryen predicted that the greatest
Kingdom man had ever known all will ever
know would be blown up so the idea of
predicting the future is not solely
isolate to aegon his foresight and
predicting of the future is something
that often happens with the targaryens
and the Clairvoyance is known as Dragon
dreaming now one of the main reasons egg
on stream wasn't known in Game of
Thrones is that he didn't tell anyone
except those next in line to the throne
and thus when they had this Civil War it
just didn't get passed along now aegon
was born to Aryan Targaryen and Lady
velena Valerian and he had an older
sister vicenya and a younger sister
rhaenis the targaryens loved incest more
than Rick and Morty and as was tradition
he was betrothed to his sister however
he did end up marrying both and he was
said to have married visenya out of Judy
whilst renice was out of Love Now whilst
aegon had this dream to take over
Westeros in order to ensure that the
Realms of man would survive there were
other matters that he had to tend to
first as we mentioned previously aegon
was born in the century of blood after
the Doom of Valeria there ended up being
a power vacuum with many vying for
control in the land of essos aegon was
approached by the cities of pentos and
tyrosh to form an alliance and defeat
volantis he ended up agreeing to this
and this started off his Conquest we saw
each of these cities in the original
Game of Thrones show when Daenerys in
her Exile ended up freeing them before
heading out into Westeros his story
somewhat mirrors that of aegons and like
they say it's like poetry they Rhyme now
with this Alliance struck with pentas
and tyrosh he flew the lease on his
Dragon to burn the fleet of Atlantis
aegon did this by riding Valerian who
was also known as the black dread we've
seen this dragon's skull which sits
under the red keep and it's also the
dragon that King viserys rode now
aegon's sister vassenia and rhenice
would also ride their own dragons vague
or a maraxus Valerian was a ridiculously
large dragon and he could cover entire
towns and shadows showing that size
Matters his sister's vicenia and rhaenys
would ride rhaegar and moraxis we've
already seen that vagar it's the guy
your girl tells you not to worry about
beggar has of course shown up in House
of the dragon and it's not the only
thing from aegon's time that carries
over bessenia saw dark sister is also
used by Damon and egg and II of course
carries his name crown and also a sword
too Heim is really a flat circle isn't
it after the clash with bellantis aegon
was now free to focus his attentions on
Westeros and he said about taking over
and uniting all the kingdoms again was
thought by some to have visited Westeros
before his invasion with there being
reports that he passed through our best
The Citadel and also lannis Port before
The Invasion began aegon would
commission the painted table and we've
seen this popping up throughout all of
the TV shows this was used by both
Stannis and Daenerys and it was a focal
point in House of the Dragons episode
10. runera also held her black Council
around this and she planned out how best
to defeat the villainous greens the
table in the book is described as being
50 feet long and 20 feet wide with a
giving a full view of Westeros so that
strategies can be formulated underneath
it one can use candles and fires to
light up the map and give an idea of how
the realm will look on fire because it's
all gonna burn
now prior to his Conquest the rulers of
Westeros were the king in the north
torrent Stark Ronald Aaron King of the
mountain and Vale Harren Hall King of
the Isles in the rivers Lauren the first
Lannister King of the rock Moon Gardner
King of the reach which is why I'm
calling myself a gilak Duran Don This
Storm King also known as argelak the
arrogant and Myra Martel princess of
dawn Harrow to butchered all those names
but moving on now Aaron had just
completed work on the mighty haran Hall
which would appear in House of the
Dragon being burned with some very
strong people inside this was known as
the tallest Castle in Westeros and its
ruler refused to bend the knee to aegon
he said that he was safe within his
walls as stoned in burn but my man
played a game of thrown and find out and
he lost very badly it said that Valerian
burned the wooden hay that lay within it
and then focused on the stone this is
said to have gone so hot that it
actually turned to Molten yeah it wasn't
exactly a good day at Harren Hall we'll
get into this morning bit but harrenhall
was also the location of the Declaration
of viserys as to Harris the first Heir
haran had been looking to expand when
argulax certain aligns with aegon but he
was mugged off when Egon asked to marry
his daughter only for aegon to offer his
friend Horus Baratheon instead furiously
our golak refused as he considered it an
insult as Oris was possibly a bastard he
ended up cutting off the hands of the NY
who sent the message and he sent one to
egg on saying these are the only hands
you will receive as we know killing a
messenger isn't something you should do
and it's so that eamon's gonna find out
firsthand now either way this led to
aegon declaring war on Westeros and he
sent a raven to each of the Kings this
proclaimed him to be the only King in
Westeros and it stipulated that those at
bend the knee who would keep their lands
in titles as we know from Game of
Thrones there's constantly a disputed
line of succession and I feel like
everyone is constantly declaring they're
the rightful ruler like Michael Scott
declaring bankruptcy now aegon began his
campaign by landing on Westroads with
his sisters and a small army of 1600 men
aegon ended up constructing the egg and
Fort and what's known as egggins Hill
this area over time became known as
King's Landing as people flocked there
once again became the king now the egg
and Ford would be replaced by the mighty
red keep which still stands to this day
well in Westeros with construction
beginning in 35 AC also joining egg
inside where the house is celt gar
Massey and lastly Valerian there appears
to be some inspiration taken from the
real-life Duke of Normandy who was more
famously known as William the Conqueror
bessenia gave him his first crown and
rhaenys named him aegon first of his
name kingable Westeros and shield of his
people now we touched on this before and
arguably one of the biggest and most
famous events of battles of the conquest
was the burning of harrenhal you talked
about this curse in other videos but
it's one of the most Savage things egg
and did and its effect has been seen
regularly across the TV shows haron's
house house [ __ ] fought against forces
but they couldn't match the dragons and
thus they hidden the castle as we talked
about earlier he mocked egg and saying
that stone doesn't burn and Megan
replied with one of the most metal lines
ever he watched him ran off about how he
was safe in his house and aegon said
when the sun sets your line shall end
again row Valerian and burnt the castle
to Ash killing Heron and his sons with
their swords being sent to the egg and
Fort every time soldiers or house
leaders were defeated the swords were
collected and sent off and I'm sure you
can guess what they got made into now
with harrenhall being destroyed egg and
looked at the stormlands and decided
they needed conquering too this led him
directly into a battle with the forces
of our Gaelic who again previously
insulted prior to the invasion this
battle was known as the last storm and
Oris Baratheon and queen renice defeated
our gillach the queen used her Dragon to
take out his men andoris defeated him in
single combat RS as you guessed it would
form house Baratheon and he took our
galaxy daughter forming the Mr steal
your daughter house here bastard and
from here aegon would go into attempt to
take the rest of Westeros which I'm
calling restauros anyway the kings of
highgarden and The Rock Moon Gardner and
Lauren Lannister formed an alliance it
was an unprecedented one and their army
was gigantic and formidable however egg
inside her dragons so no matter what
it's still even the playing field the
battle was known as the Field of Fire
and almost 4 000 men were killed or
burned during this attack the Gardner
line ended a pretty much extinct after
this with a fight killing the King and
all his sons it ended up with Lauren
Banning the knee and another name you
might recognize being given lordship
over Hightower all in Terrell was
rewarded after yielding the castle with
the titles of Lord of highgarden Lord
Paramount of the mandare and one of the
South being given the north whose Nexus
torrent Stark was marching to face the
targaryens but something happened which
was very very unlike the northmen that
we've come to know in the show in books
Stark would go on to yield to aegon and
he became the Lord of Winterfell and
Warden of the north however with this
also came a little less of a Savory name
and throughout the Legends he's been
known as the king who knelt after
watching the end of Game of Thrones and
the revelation of Egan's dream and House
of the Dragon this meaning has some
fresh Light Shone on it the Sarah said
how there must be a Targaryen on the
iron throne and mentioned the Song of
Ice and Fire the ice could be the Frozen
wastelands the white walkers come from
but it could also be the stocks the
Starks were unabound and beautiful men
so what would cause a stubborn house
like this to yield to a foreign beta
perhaps Tarn yielded because the details
of the dream and the knowledge that
there's something evil Beyond the Wall
the piece was made his turn and realized
about the burning of harrenhal and the
Field of Fire would show that dragons
ain't nothing left with and the whale
was next which was won by vicenia simply
flying Veigar to meet the young king
Ronald Aaron he asked for a ride on the
back and he was so impressed that he
ended up kneeling so yeah nice one there
and this was the despite his mother
region trying to secure an alliance by
the way of marriage making run on the
air which was obviously refused the only
place not to be conquered was The Dawn
and it wouldn't be until 3 I see that
again would try and go back in order to
complete the set he was lying it up like
a shiny charizard that was just Out Of
Reach like a gummy De Milo Dawn proved
to be the hardest place to conquer and
the Hand of King Oris ended up being
captured things went from bad to worse
as Raines fell into NAC after the dragon
maraxis was shot down from the sky it
was a long and brutal war and it also
appeared to have no end again was almost
killed twice and this is why the king's
God was formed so that he had his Royal
protectors as the best fighters in the
land in 13ac the Bloodshed ended and
Nightmare Martel the prince of dawn sent
the skull of moraxis to aegon this also
brought with it a letter that accepted
the contents leading to finally the
conquest of the Seven Kingdoms being
carried out now the world at this point
was pretty much laid out how it is in
the show and it's extremely similar to
what we've seen in the series as the
king ironically aegon attempted to be a
peaceful ruler and he established the
king's piece where conflict can only be
decided by the Iron Throne that Throne
is forged using the swords of his
defeated enemies and he rewarded RS
baratheon's service by making him hand
of the king he also became a father in
7ac to Anis and would later father Megan
the cruel well maegor at the time with
Hussein about 11 AC there were rumors
that she was actually Barren and a lot
of people wondered whether anes was a
legitimate the iron Islands were secured
in 2ac and once the kingdoms United the
realm enjoyed what was known as the
dragon's piece aegon attempted to
assimilate into westerosi culture many
Builders September senior Hill and also
one on rhaenius's other major
constructions included the giant wall of
King's Landing as well as the red keep
because again 4 wasn't Fit For A King
aegon died in 37 AC and Dragonstone at
the age of 64 and he was cremated
similar to viserys's wife Emma which we
saw in house of the Dragon he was
succeeded by Anis the first and Meg or
the cruel which is a whole video in
itself well there you have it The Life
and Times of egg on the Conqueror the
legendary figure who did The Impossible
and United the Seven Kingdoms obviously
I'd love to hear your thoughts on the
character so make sure you drop a
comment below and let me know we are in
competition right now and giving away
three copies of top gun Maverick on the
15th of November and all you have to do
to be on the chance of winning is like
the video make sure you subscribe and
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the
character repeat the comments at random
on the 15th and the winners of the last
one are on screen right now so that's
you then message me on Twitter at heavy
spoilers if you want something else to
watch make sure you check out one of our
house of the Dragon breakdowns which
will be linked on screen right now
having a lot of fun talking about the
show especially now it's over not a mad
rush to get things out at 2AM in the
morning so yeah having fun with it and I
hope you are too hopefully I see you
around one of those videos but if not
enjoy the rest of your week take care
peace